here's iran's hardline newspaper praise
of salman rushdie's attacker this is a
reuters story the hardline
kahan newspaper whose editor-in-chief is
appointed by iran's supreme leader ali
khamenei wrote
a thousand bravos to the brave and
dutiful person who attacked
the apostate and evil salman rushdie in
new york adding the hand that the man
who tore the neck of god's enemy must be
kissed
the asser iran news site on saturday
carried an often cited quote by khamenei
that said the arrow shot by khomeini
will one day hit the target the headline
of the hard line vatan m ruse uh
newspaper read a knife in salman
rushdie's neck the hostron
headline satan on the way to hell so
here's here's the thing
with these stories okay that you have to
be keeping in mind
bill maher said something a couple days
ago because you know salman rush is one
of his friends a good friend of us
and you know he's probably going to lose
his eye by the way okay and oh really
yeah he's probably going to lose his eye
and do you know what he was talking on
at this event he was talking about on
the freedoms to be able to talk about
whatever you can write about and talk
about that's what this whole tour was
about so he's going out there talking
about that and this guy comes in stabs
him three times in the neck four in the
stomach in the eye gonna lose his eye in
bad conditions he's making it
whether you like simon rushdie or not or
agree with what he wrote or not
you know bill is trying to say
name me any other religion that their
extremists are doing things like this
and he says as much as america wants to
avoid this topic it is a discussion that
we must have so now couple things do you
remember years ago when trump uh uh
under his regime they killed hassan
soleimani do you remember when that
happened yeah they arrived
yeah we talked about the revenge and you
know how long ago
the airport missile that's right
so what did they say oh you know revenge
is coming it's going to come on whose
terms
on their terms you know it's not going
to these guys in iran they don't forget
this is not something they sit on and
they move on to them
it's just a matter of time before they
get there especially right now i don't
know how many stories you're reading
about the fact that iran wants to go
after trump did you see these stories
about uh
they just tried to kill john bolton too
they just tried to kill john bolton
trump's another one that they have on
their list but look this is real this
isn't like you know these types of
stories when you're reading him and
you're hearing the
support from the back to say kissing the
hand of the person who the hand of the
man who toward the next of god's enemy
must be kissed
being written by this paper
that is the editor-in-chief is appointed
by iran's supreme leader ali khamenei
you know you have to you have to
understand these types of things don't
happen in america
these types of things happen
it's stories like this that gets you to
realize freedom of speech in america
this is not happening from an american
to an american this kid that did this
the 24 year old that was connected to
the iran to iran you know where he lives
this kid is he was born in california
it's not like he was born in iran yeah
this kid's a u.s citizen
natural born he was born here and they
get to him and he goes up there and does
what he does and right now you know
we're going to see what's going to
happen with it but um i hope more of
this doesn't become a normalized thing
we don't get too many of these stories
happening
it's unfortunate that they did it to him
i remember when the father happened they
were burning his book all over the place
and quite frankly
the the book
is actually not that great of a book
the fact that they gave him a fatwa
took his book to you know levels of
selling god knows how many copies
because khomeini gave him that fatwa
there's literally celebrations where
have you seen these videos they're
around fire and they're throwing the
book in fire they bought his book to
burn it they bought it that's exactly
amazon has a 10 pack for those of you
going to the inferno this afternoon
well it's ironically what's making me
think of is just free market capitalism
is because look at prohibition
no more liquor in america that's it well
what happened people were making
moonshine in their bathtubs so this is
one of those things where it's like no
don't don't don't look over here no
salman rushi it's like that's just gonna
empower
more people to be like hold on why can't
i go what do you mean hold on and and it
essentially enabled his book to come
become a national bestseller
international bestseller but when you
try to
outlaw things
black markets uh emerge and not that he
needed a black market to sell his books
but if you try to
stomp out something it's going to
re-emerge as something else and that's
the problem that iran is did you hear
about what happened with jk rowling when
jk rowling goes up there and she says
you know i hope he's okay she says this
on twitter
uh horrifying news feeling very sick
right now let let him be okay
and somebody responded on twitter a guy
named uh mir asif aziz
replied don't worry you are next okay as
this is reportedly an iran-backed
islamist extremist praising rushdie's
attacker it's it's i mean and by the way
i'm curious did this person get banned
on twitter or are they still active on
twitter tyler do you know this of course
they're still active i'm trying to find
the article now yeah they find that out
though it's it's um the kid deleted his
account so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
you